[Musique]
à l'extrême opposé de la capitale
moderne du caire le plateau de guizeh
sont vastes ensembles funéraires inclut
les pyramides de sefrou et de son fils
des frênes monuments colossaux à la
gloire de leurs bâtisseurs
il marque également la fin d'une apogée
de l'egypte ancienne
[Musique]
après deux siècles au cours desquelles
on s'est attaché à construire des
pyramides de plus en plus imposantes le
dernier pharaon a laissé sa trace
architectural à gizeh achève un monument
dont la taille fait à peine le tiers de
celle de ses voisins une seule et même
question continue de tarauder les
spécialistes
pourquoi
[Musique]
laon 2532 avant jésus-christ voit
l'avènement du pharaon mykérinos dans sa
ligne il figure comme cinquième
descendant de la ivème dynastie
[Musique]
fils du pharaon kephren il est probable
que nick et rhinos et hériter d'un
royaume dans les projets architecturaux
se sont heurtés aux limites de
l'autorité royale
[Musique]
tout laisse penser que l'on est en effet
commencé à pointer du doigt le coût
pharaonique de l'entretien des centaines
de milliers d'ouvriers envolé dans les
travaux des grandes pyramides de gizeh
l'écrivain du vème siècle hérodote écrit
d'ailleurs que l'egypte aurait traversé
une période de 106 ans d' extrême misère
due à la fermeture des temples parce
néphro et kephren afin de forcer les
fidèles au labeur
ah non à l'encontre de ses pairs
mykérinos aurait rouvert ses temples de
sorte que le peuple puisse à nouveau
rendre librement son culte
on pense que les portraits de pierre que
le pharaon a fait sculpter à sa gloire
symbolisant retour sa bonté il pose ici
aux côtés de la préférée de ces trois
femmes kamerhe née petit
dans une démonstration d'affection
plutôt inhabituelle elle les trains
d'une main pendant que l'autre repose
paisiblement sur son bras
la légende veut que l'autorité
bienveillante de miki rhinos était perçu
par les dieux comme un affront ceci
aurait condamné l'egypte à 150 ans
d'oppression
une sanction dont sol ses deux
prédécesseurs auraient été avertis
[Musique]
c'était un bon roi ce qui a contrarié
les dieux car il allait à l'opposé de
leurs professeurs pour se venger
ils ont donc décidé de ne lui a accordé
que six ans de vie avant un retour aux
troubles des règnes précédent mais
évidemment ça n'a pas du tout convenu
amitié rhinos qui s'est efforcé de
continuer à contredire les dieux la
légende nous raconte qu'il aurait fait à
portée des bougies et les aurait fait
allumée en permanence de sorte qu'ils
puissent rester éveillé nuit et gêné
ainsi mykérinos calcule-t-il qu'il peut
s'offrir le luxe de renier deux fois
plus longtemps et remplir 12 ans au lieu
de six son rôle de braves pharaons
d'égypte
à la faveur de ses bougies il demeurera
en réalité pas moins de 28 ans sur le
trône
jusqu'en 2005 105 avant jésus-christ son
règne ne le voit pourtant construire une
pyramide relativement modeste
[Musique]
les spécialistes on cherche toujours la
raison est ce la conjoncture économique
ou bien attend carrément remis en
question la puissance du pharaon
la pyramide de la terrine hausse est la
plus petites des 3 2 ghz et il est très
difficile de savoir véritablement
pourquoi son règne d'un certain pas été
très lent mais l'on connaît des cas de
pharaon qui ont fait bâtir d'imposants
monument bien qu'il soit resté peu de
temps pouvoir il faut se garder de
chercher là une explication
spectaculaires comme une quelconque
faiblesse du pharaon est resté plutôt
sur l'intuition qu'à cette époque la
valeur de monuments égyptiens n'est plus
forcément proportionnel à sa taille
d'autres historiens avancent l'hypothèse
que la taille de l'édifice aurait été
dicté par le choix des matériaux de
construction
on ne sait pas pourquoi la pyramide demi
kirino c'est la plus petite des trois de
guizeh on a peut être voulu y incorporer
une pierre plus difficile à façonner
il a certainement été question d'en
chasser la base dans du granit un
matériau effectivement plus dur à
travailler que le calcaire qui était
jusque-là communément utilisé de la même
manière on ne sait pas non plus pourquoi
celle de snefc roux est la plus grande
ni pourquoi celle de khephren et de
cette taille et pas d'une autre
on sait par contre que le règne du
pharaon mykérinos doit s'achever la
ivème dynastie
c'est le début d'une ère de
bouleversements et l'avènement d'une
nouvelle lignée de pharaon
ainsi en 2004 198 avant jésus-christ
débute en egypte ancienne sous le
pharaon roussir caf la 5ème dynastie
ou sert caf dont le nom signifie celui
dans l'âme et profonde n'est autre que
le petit fils du pharaon ce n'est frau
il s'est offert son titre en épousant la
fille de mick irin ans
s'il ne reste que peu de temps sur le
trône il montre néanmoins qu'il refuse
de suivre la tradition funéraire de ses
prédécesseurs en préférant au plateau de
gizeh le lieu de saqqara comme
emplacement de sa pyramide le monument
qui a très mal résisté à l'épreuve du
temps se tient presque dans l'ombre de
la pyramide à degrés de jazzer
[Musique]
ou sur caf est aussi l'initiateur d'un
culte religieux à la seule gloire du
soleil bien que le temple construit à
cet effet est disparu depuis longtemps
les spécialistes sont parvenus à en
reconstituer une description grâce à
l'héritage des temple solaire qu'ils
l'ont suivi
à l'image de celui du ser caf les temple
du soleil consistait en un obélisque
emblématique du soleil dressée sur une
base de pierres et faisant face à une
large cours abritant un hôtel ou un lieu
d'offrandes
tout porte à croire qu'on faisait à cet
endroit des offrandes au soleil c'est
même temple semblé aussi être en lien
étroit avec l'association du roi avec le
dieu solaire puisque dans leur vie après
la mort les rois se voyait investi de ce
statut divin la 5éme dynastie du rush
150 ans et s'achèvera sous le règne du
pharaon ou nas sur l'élan de ses pairs
c'est également à saqqara qu'il fait
ériger sa pyramide
[Musique]
bien qu'elle soit extérieurement en très
mauvais état
son intérieur renferme toujours les
premiers textes découverts sur les murs
de pyramide
[Musique]
c'est hiéroglyphes représente une série
de formules destinées à aider le pharaon
dans son passage vers l'au delà
[Musique]
les scribes de l'antiquité ont à leur
tour
recopier sur papyrus ces instructions
gravés dans la pierre illustré avec un
sens pointu du détail
cette compilation décrit forme ce que
l'on appelle le livre égyptien des morts
pendant 2000 ans les égyptiens liron et
réciteront ce véritable guide de la vie
après la mort qui constitue à ce jour
l'un des chefs-d'oeuvre les plus
précieux de toute la culture d'anciennes
egypte
elle ou nas dont l'existence est
éternelle ton essence est aux cieux ton
corps et sur terre ton coeur une as
reposent parmi ceux qui sur cette terre
continueront aussi à vivre à jamais
avec la mort du pharaon menaçant 2345
avant jésus-christ s'achève la cinquième
dynastie le pharaon pépi inaugure la
sixième une statuette d'albâtre de pépi
le monde raccompagné du dieu faucon en
russe
[Musique]
curieusement cependant l'oiseau se tient
à distance derrière le trône comme si
tout à coup ce dieu d'une importance
capitale se désintéressait du pharaon
les écrits sur pepy nous enseigne que
sous son règne la classe dominante gagne
en influence
en même temps qu'elle s'enrichit que son
pouvoir absolu dictée depuis la ville de
memphis perd en crédibilité et que son
royaume court au désastre
[Musique]
cette statue de bronze de pépi premier
le montre au crépuscule de son pouvoir
d'un demi siècle après son décès en 2002
183 avant jésus-christ c'est son fils
pepy 2 qui lui succède alors qu'il n'a
que 6 ans
[Musique]
le nouveau pharaon a hérité du nom de
son père à 6 ans pépi ii devient le
souverain de toute l'egypte
mais que doit attendre d'un enfant de 6
ans un pays en pleine croissance
on a quelques exemples de pharaon ayant
accédé très jeune au trône
finalement un enfant de 6 ans ne pouvait
que suivre ce qu'on lui ordonnait de
faire vous pouvez être sûr que même si
l'on percevait sa nature comme divine et
s'ils détenaient en théorie le pouvoir
politique suprême
juste derrière lui il y avait une
assemblée de conseillers qui s'occupait
de gérer le royaume
jusqu'à ce qu'ils atteignent l'âge de
prendre le relais en tant que véritable
pharaons
le jeune garçon ne restent pas cependant
sans exercer une quelconque influence
au cours d'une expédition de négoce
mener vers assouan on rapporte aux
genevois alors âgé de 8 ans qu'on a
capturé un danseur pygmées pour le
ramener en egypte
[Musique]
amener le mois tout de suite à la cour
rapporté moissonnant sains et saufs
afin qu'ils réjouissent et réchauffe le
coeur du roi des hautes et basses egypte
quand vous le mettrez à bord de votre
bateau soyez certain de n'avoir engagé
que le meilleur personnel qui soit il
devra veiller sur lui et s'assurer
qu'ils ne tombent pas aller si vous
revenez jusqu'à la cour avec ce nain
sains et saufs majesté vous rendra les
meilleurs sonneurs qui soit quand bien
même un pharaon n'était encore qu'un
enfant il avait droit à la plus grande
différence
on prenait acte du moindre de ses désirs
en s'efforçant de le combler puisque cet
enfant incarné déjà est par essence
l'aspect divin du pharaon
par conséquent même si l'on gardait une
emprise très ferme sur les décisions
politiques ses désirs s'interpréter
comme une manifestation du caractère
divin de son autorité ce qui nécessitait
de rester très indulgent à son égard
mais sous le règne de l'enfant pepy de
l'autorité du pharaon fini à la fin de
la vième dynastie par se désintégrer
toute une succession d'administrateur
autoproclamé indépendant met en place
peu à peu une sorte de régime féodal
non
les nobles sont devenus misérables alors
que les pauvres profitent des plaisirs
de la vie l'or l'argent et le turquoise
est un [__] coût des femmes esclaves
alors que les dames traverse les rues
vêtus de loques quiconque marchait
autrefois sans même une paire de
sandales trône à présent sur une
quantité de trésors le pouvoir ceux des
centres de même fils à force de faire
des cadeaux à ses nobles leroy finit par
épuiser ses trésors à la mort de pépi ii
en 2000 180 avant jésus-christ le
royaume d'egypte se disloque pendant
plus de mille ans la civilisation
égyptienne s'est épanoui à l'ombre des
falaises de la vallée du nil
adossé au désert jusqu'en 2100 80 avant
jésus-christ les égyptiens se sont
illustrés par de magnifiques
réalisations dans les domaines de l'art
de la science et de la technologie
[Musique]
en architecture les premières mastaba
plainte bâti à partir de boue séchée ont
cédé la place à d'imposantes pyramide de
pierre partie de simple relief mureaux
l'art de l'écriture s'est élevé vers la
littérature infiniment riche des textes
des pyramides
ces critères de l'ancien royaume
d'égypte détermine précisément la base
sur laquelle on continuera d'appréhender
les réalisations ultérieure de cette
magnifique civilisation les historiens
suggère que les égyptiens dans ce double
contexte de splendeurs naturelles et de
merveilles issus de leur intelligence
seraient devenus un peuple
orgueilleux et suffisant amorcée sous le
règne du très jeune pharaon pépi 2
l'effondrement du pays se poursuit
jusqu'en 2100 84 avant jésus-christ
s'ensuit le période de transition qu'il
y eu 40 ans et s'étale sur 4 dynastie
[Musique]
on cherche toujours les véritables
explications de ce déclin
[Musique]
mais hormis la trace d'un poème
partiellement préserver sur papyrus les
écrits anciens reste mystérieusement
muet
[Musique]
voyez comment des choses qu'ils
n'arrivaient pas auparavant arrive à
présent
ce sont les mendiants qui adore le roi
regardez ce qu'est devenu celui qu'on
avait enterré comme le faucon suprême sa
pyramide s'est vidé de ce trésor
voyez comment quelques personnes au
mépris des traditions ont dépossédé
cette terre de sa royauté
[Musique]
des documents retrouvés dans la région
d'herat clio police révèle qu'après
avoir à nouveau divisé le pays en deux
régions distinctes une série de roy
éphémère se succèdent à la tête de la
basse egypte c'est désormais depuis la
ville nouvelle de thèmes que l'on régit
la haute egypte les anciens décrivent
cette période d'instabilité commune air
ayant vu défiler 70 roi en 70 jours
un chaos qui en vérité ne durera pas
moins de 200 ans
[Musique]
des cendres de l'ancien royaume et du
marasme ambiant leroy montaut tapez le
phare en surgissant comme le nouvel
unificateur de l'egypte
lui-même se présente comme l'artisan de
cette unité
il consacre la première partie de son
règne a orchestré les campagnes
militaires visant à réprimer toute
tentative de révolte contre son autorité
notamment tout premier était
véritablement partie de ces chefs
d'égypte très dynamique
c'est l'un des plus grands pharaons qui
existait parce qu'il est arrivé à une
époque où l'egypte était déchirée où
elle avait politiquement éclaté il est
parvenu sous son règne à réunifier le
pays et a dressé les plans d'une
réorganisation très pointu ainsi que
d'une nouvelle centralisation du pouvoir
qui ont rendu sa toute puissance à la
royauté
le pharaon mantoue otep dirige le pays
depuis thèbes devenue capitale thème qui
sera plus tard célèbre pour ses
sanctuaires de louxor et de carnac
sous son règne taib est déjà une ville
immense et puissante
les anciens en parle comme de la ville
aux mille portes du point de vue
architectural
elle incarne la stabilité et la
prospérité retrouvée
[Musique]
mais à linverse de ses prédécesseurs
montrent aux hôtesses ne jouit plus du
statut de demi-dieu afin de redorer son
image
il se fait bâtir un nouveau style de
temple funéraire avec pour toile de fond
les impressionnantes falaises dr el
bahri
creusée à même la roche
la nécropole mélange de masta main
traditionnelle et d'imposantes pyramide
confirme le retour en force d'un
souverain milieu guillaume
[Musique]
on retrouvera sous le temple une statue
de pierre d'un bon tout est plus grand
que nature
le pharaon est représentée assise est
paré de sa robe de cérémonie du
renouveau le fdd cède près de cette
oeuvre repose un relief montre ans à
rennes qu'à 8 se faisant coiffer par une
servante
parmi les artefacts que nos livres la
tombe figure d'autre part cette peinture
de la princesse h ait se relaxant et
humant le parfum à des fleurs de lotus
autant de scènes en somme soulignant une
paix et une stabilité retrouver un
équilibre qui perdure tout au long du
règne de ce pharaon considéré comme
l'instigateur d'une toute nouvelle
conception de l'autorité
[Musique]
ce personnage à l'expression au sein des
soucieuse n'est autre que ces hausses
triste roi le pharaon qui accède au
trône en 1878 avant jésus-christ on
connaît bien ces hausses triste roi
parce que le passé nous a légué de
nombreuses statues de lui toutes sont
assez saisissante et nous montre un roi
qui s'efforce de prendre son rôle très
au sérieux
il se présente comme un souverain a visé
très prudent qui veut absolument
défendre le caractère tout puissant de
la royauté
[Musique]
son nom signifie d'ailleurs hommes de
pouvoir mais à la différence de ses
aïeuls que l'on s'attache à dépeindre
comme des dieux il s'agit dans les
statuts de ces hausses triste roi de
montrer l'homme plus vrai que nature
ses paupières lourdes sans visages
croisés d'ohrid ses lèvres pincées
annonce la nature austère et cérébral
que l'on s'attend à rencontrer chez un
grand chef militaire
[Musique]
c'est austry ce droit est resté comme le
symbole d'un grand chef d'armée on le
voit d'ailleurs à travers ses campagnes
en nubie où il a essayé d'étendre la
puissance de l'egypte en même temps qu
il en défend des les frontières c'est
également sous son règne qu'il développe
des citadelle construite à partir de
briques de terre après que les égyptiens
et bâti les premiers modèles à la
frontière sud de la nubie aujourd'hui
nord du soudan
certaines de ces forteresses ont
d'ailleurs un rôle plus commercial que
militaire elles servent notamment de
lieu de transit aux matériaux de
construction qui lui permettent de bâtir
tout au long de son avance et
expansionniste la région de haute tenue
be était à l'époque au lieu d'une
culture très puissante appelé la culture
car noir ses os christ roi a cherché à
faire barrage en particulier grâce à ces
citadelles à une culture dont il ne
voulait pas pour son pays
un relief témoigne de la campagne menée
par le pharaon
j'ai marqué moi aussi ma frontière
mais je suis aller plus au sud encore
que mes ancêtres j'ai fait fructifier ce
qui m'a été légué j'ai capturé leurs
femmes et arrêter les hommes qui
allaient au puy et mener le bétail
j'ai fauché leur blé puis brûlé leurs
terres sur mon passage
[Musique]
la plupart de cette richesse accaparé au
cours de ces campagnes en nubie lui sert
à ériger de nouveaux temples en egypte
il fait bâtir dans la capitale de thèbes
un temple aujourd'hui disparu dédié au
dieu mantoue dieu de la guerre sous
l'egypte antique
[Musique]
mais cette confiance dans les dieux de
la guerre est passagère en l'espace de
deux cents ans
le fier peuple égyptien va subir l'ombre
d'invasion et basculer à nouveau dans le
chaos
et
non
[Musique]
s'il est vrai qu aucun monument ni
représentation picturale ne célèbrent
leur règne des écrits anciens nous
révèle qu'en 16 163 avant jésus-christ
des phares ronds d'origine sémites les
hyksos prennent le contrôle de l'egypte
[Musique]
on ne sait pas exactement par quels
moyens les hyksos ont pris le pouvoir en
egypte peut-être est-ce en partie en
s'infiltrant discrètement par le delta
du nil
à moins qu'il y ait eu une véritable
invasion organiser s'il s'agit bien
d'une invasion les hyksos se serait
alors mis à conquérir le pays armé d'un
nouvel outil l'arc
il aurait également introduit en egypte
le cheval et le char les anciens nomme
ces véhicules tractés par des chevaux
les bateaux naviguant sur les sables du
désert
[Musique]
il y a lieu de penser que les hyksos et
chercher à piler memphis capitale
culturelle et politique de l'egypte
leur mainmise sur le pays voit
l'avènement de la 16ème dynastique qui
durera 108 ans
non pas du tout apprécié cette hégémonie
étrangères elle les a marqués très
profondément au point qu après être
parvenu à bouter les hyksos hors de
leurs frontières
les égyptiens ont continué à vivre dans
ce que j'appelle le syndrome du plus
jamais ça
il n'était pas question que ça
recommence un jour une fois les rois
étrangers expulsés les égyptiens
choisissent de s'en tenir à leurs
frontières et insistait l'émergence d'un
nouveau royaume depuis l'ancienne ville
de thèbes
[Musique]
les pharaons emblématique de ce nouveau
royaume se projette plus que jamais
comme des êtres de nature divine
leurs immenses tentes les monuments ont
marqué l'egypte d'une empreinte qui
persiste depuis trois millénaires
cette 18ème dynastie ou lignée de
pharaon débute en 1570 avant
jésus-christ avec le roi à maurice une
mosaïque contemporaine à son règne le
montre prenant son d'un rituel de
purification
[Musique]
on prête aux pharaons amosis d'avoir
fermé les frontières avec la syrie et la
libye afin d'empêcher de nouvelles
invasions la représentation de sa hache
de guerre en or
un accessoire de cérémonie le confirme
comme chef militaire suprême dans une
scène où on le voit frappant l'ennemi
bien que ça tombait été pillés des
trésors qu'elle renfermait très
probablement sa momie est demeurée
intacte
c'est pour nous l'occasion unique de
contempler le visage de ce pharaon
fondateur de la xviiie dynastie
[Musique]
le temps nous a également légué le corps
momifié de son successeur tout moses
premier souverain d'égypte des 1535
avant jésus-christ
[Musique]
bien que son règne n'ait duré que six
ans on le crédite d'une série de
brillante campagne militaire lui ayant
permis de repousser davantage les
frontières d'égypte sur les riches
terres minière de nubie
et
lors de son passage par la nécropole
d'abidos touthmôsis premier laissera une
inscription sur laquelle il relate lui
même ses hauts faits
j'ai repoussé les frontières de l'egypte
jusqu'à ce que le soleil les entoure
j'ai fait de l'egypte de la terre
supérieure à toutes les autres
[Musique]
le nom de tout mosys signifie née du
dieu thot en hommage à la divinité
égyptienne de la lune et du savoir
avant sa mort en 1518 avant jésus-christ
après donc six années de règne tout
moses premier passe le flambeau à son
fils tout moses 2
à cette époque seuls les familles
royales égyptienne encourage le mariage
entre frère et soeur de sorte que soit
assuré une ligne echos' andine
permettant d'hériter du trône en toute
confiance
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que tout mosys deux épouses
sa propre demi-soeur hatshepsout dont le
nom désigne la plus éminente d'entre les
femmes nobles tous deux gouverne côte à
côte pendant 14 ans mais le pharaons
touthmôsis 2 n'est que l'ombre du père
tout puissant dont il a hérité
il règne sur une période peu mouvementée
et lorsqu'il meurt à l'âge de 30 ans il
laisse une famille royale en proie à un
grave dilemme
parmi ces seuls légataire potentiels
figurent en effet un jeune garçon qui
n'a pas encore douze ans la mère de
l'enfant est une femme du harem dunant
d'isis on place malgré tout à la tête du
royaume le jaune tout mot 6 3 cet enfant
qui se trouvait être bien entendu le
neveu d'hatchepsout qui a bénéficié le
premier du droit d'héritier du trône
puisqu'il était le descendant masculin
immédiat du roi décédé
mais comme il était justement bien trop
jeune hatshepsout s'est installé avec
lui comme co régente pour finalement
exercer cette fonction pendant plus de
20 ans
en réalité après deux ans de corée jans
la reine hatchepsout usurpe le pouvoir
de son beau fils et se fait couronner
pharaons en 1498 avant jésus-christ elle
devient ainsi souveraine l'egypte le
pays le plus riche et le plus puissant
du monde
[Musique]
niché dans les contreforts des falaises
de dr elle marie serait de thèbes se
tient à remarquable chef-d'oeuvre le
temple funéraire de la reine hatchepsout
elle-même surnommait ce site le jardin
de mon père à mon le plus puissant des
dieux de thèmes c'était effectivement un
jardin très raffinée dans les rampes de
l'entrée était bordée de nombreux arbres
et arbustes verdoyant un ornement
végétales dont on sait qu'il s'étendait
jusque sur les colonnades et le long du
sanctuaire
plus qu'un temple ce lieu est pour
hatshepsout un instrument de propagande
destinée à justifier sa montée sur le
trône
la reine a fait peindre sur ses murs des
scènes montrant son père défunt
touthmôsis premier lui conférant les
pleins pouvoirs
la plupart des scènes que le temple
funéraire d'hatchepsout tu nous offres
de contempler nous présente sa
souveraineté d'une façon très idéalisée
on sent que par ses peintures elle
s'efforce de revendiquer son droit au
titre de reine
on peut donc dire que ce texte n'est pas
en soi un document historique qui relate
des faits réels mais quelque chose en
grande partie monté par elle pour
essayer de renforcer ses pouvoirs
des pouvoirs ketchup soude consolide
davantage encore par la pratique du
culte religieux et l'entremise des
prêtres du temple d'amon l'autorité de
ses prêtres est importante puisqu'il
venait précisément un dieu dont on pense
qu'ils donnent toute leur force aux
pharaons et bien qu'il ait été interdit
aux femmes de participer à ces
cérémonies religieuses hatshepsout en
tant que pharaon s'arrogent le droit de
pénétrer dans la maison de dieu
à l'extérieur du temple elle commandite
la construction d'un impressionnant
obélisque célébrant sa relation avec le
dieu solaire
si l'on ne dispose d'aucun document sur
les capacités d'hatchepsout à conduire
une armée elle se démarque en revanche
par ses expéditions commerciales vers la
terre de pount aujourd'hui la somalie
des gravures montre sa flotte traversant
la mer rouge et ses hommes échangeant
des pierres précieuses contre des
arbustes de bosses vélia destiné à
fabriquer l'ensemble de la reine
[Musique]
un homme du peuple du nom de scène
mouthe gère les affaires de la reine
pharaon hatshepsout
[Musique]
il semble qu'il ait assisté pendant la
majeure partie de sa vie des statuts le
représente tenant délicatement la fille
d'hatchepsout la princesse née ferrures
à ou bien s'occupant de son éducation
à l'époque la rumeur va bon train sur la
nature de la relation qui lie cette
voûte à sa reine
on prétend qu'il doit sa place à
l'intimité qu'ils entretiennent en aval
du temple funéraire d'hatchepsout août
on a retrouvé enfoui profondément sous
terre la tong seng août avait fait
construire pour lui même
la proximité des deux sépultures laisse
effectivement croire à une possible
relation amoureuse
hatshepsout décède en 1483 avant
jésus-christ mais curieusement tous
documents faisant état de 7 morts semble
avoir été détruits certains suggèrent
que tout mosys 3 l'enfant dont elle
avait usurpé le titre aurait participé à
sa disparition
on sait simplement que tout mosys 3 la
détestais au point de se venger bientôt
sur tout ce qui la symbolisent
[Musique]
l'enfant en effet patienter pas moins de
20 ans avant de pouvoir reprendre son
titre
[Musique]
vingt années passées dans l'ombre d'une
tante auto proclamée reine et dont on
s'est alors évertué à raconter qu'il
adorait
[Musique]
après la mort de la reine hatchepsout
touthmôsis iii redevient donc en 1504
avant jésus-christ le célèbre pharaon de
la xviiie dynastie égyptienne
[Musique]
il est probable que tout mot 6-3 pendant
qu'on le maintenait à l'écart est suivi
une formation militaire
à l'instar des autres nobles de son
époque il a appris à manier l'arc et les
flèches ainsi qu'à conduire un char à
travers le désert
[Musique]
aussi commence-t-il à faire preuve de
ses prouesses militaires dès sa seconde
année de règne les écrits de l'époque
témoignent des dix huit années au cours
desquelles ils livrent bataille et mène
toute une série de campagnes le long des
côtes de syrie une période qui le voit
s'enrichir considérablement et poussera
les historiens le comparé à napoléon
[Musique]
on le surnomme le napoléon de l'egypte
parce que c'est l'un des personnages
militaires les plus éminents de toute
l'histoire de la royauté égyptienne il a
mené une série impressionnante de
campagne militaire bien plus que l'on
fait la plupart des pharaons des côtes
est et ouest de la méditerranée
ils participaient huit même physiquement
à beaucoup de batailles il consacre le
butin rapportés de ses campagnes à
embellir et agrandir de nombreux temples
de son pays
parmi les travaux les plus éblouissants
qu'il réalise ce du temple de karnak
bâtie sur les ruines de tep
[Musique]
à l'extrémité est du vaste ensemble
religieux il fait élever son temple du
obsède ou fête du renouveau
[Musique]
l' architecture de l'édifice est unique
en son genre on pense que ces colonnes
d'une forme pour le moins inhabituel et
veut que les piquets de sa tante
militaire quant aux autres murs et
colonnes du site
ils illustrent les variétés de plantes
et d'animaux rapporté de sa campagne en
syrie
rec mire hauts fonctionnaires ou vizir
du pharaon supervise l'ensemble du
projet cette peinture murale le montre
inspectant la fabrication des briques
par les ouvriers du roi
mais tout maurice 3 a beau être un
entrepreneur très productif
c'est aussi un destructeur acharnée au
cours des vingt ans qui suivent la
disparition de jeeps sont secondaires
par une armée de fidèles partisans
il s'attache à détruire systématiquement
toute trace historique de son ancienne
tutrice il n'a pas toléré l'usurpation
de sa place sur le trône et ils se
vengent autant qu'il le peut
il fait abattre les statuts de son
temple
certaines sont décapités d'autres
fracassé au sol
[Musique]
on est face au burin son visage des
reliefs mûron
on fait table rase du moindre document
évoquant son règne
même les statuts de son commandant en
chef et compagnes enseignement août
n'échappe pas aux dégradations
[Musique]
il s'agit ni plus ni moins d'un
véritable autodafé en gommant ainsi
l'image et le nom de james hook
touthmôsis iii pan s'affranchir de son
souvenir en même temps qu'ils espèrent
anéantir toute chance de survie de son
âme
cette même xviiie dynastie de farrar on
s'aperçoit qu'elle n'a jamais
véritablement profiter de la splendeur
de son grand sphinx de gizeh déjà vieux
de mille ans
[Musique]
le sable s'est accumulée et recouvre le
monument c'est un nouveau pharaons
touthmôsis 4 qui sous sa première année
de règne en 1419 avant jésus-christ
décide de désensabler le sphinx entre
les pattes de la grande bête du désert
une imposante plaques de pierres gravées
témoigne de l'événement
vous voyez ici une reproduction de la
plaque proposant au pied du grand sphinx
le début du texte se trouve sur la
partie supérieure droite
l'indic la date à laquelle on l'a gravé
pendant son règne on peut lire ensuite
le récit d'une aventure tout à fait
extraordinaire un jour le roi s'en va
chasser des autruches et des lions dans
le désert qui s'étend derrière les
pyramides pour marquer une pause
il décide de faire une petite sieste et
s'étend aux frais à l'ombre de la tête
du sphinx leroy rapporte qu'au cours de
son sommes à l'ombre du sphinx
ce dernier se serait mis à lui parler
regarde-moi touthmôsis mon fils je suis
ton père jusqu'à l'horizon j'ai à
présent hâte offrir l'autorité terrestre
sur tout être vivant
je t'offre toutes les terres sur
lesquelles le soleil pose sa lumière
je m'en remets tout entier à ta
bienveillance les sables du lieu saint
où je repose ont fini par me recouvrir
mon corps me fait mal je suis exténuée
[Musique]
et il a continué si tu te soucie de mon
apparence à leur rang moi mon visage
dégage moi de tout ce qui me gêne et je
ferai de toi non seulement le roi de
l'egypte mais l'un des plus grands
souverains que l'egypte ait connu
pendant 33 ans tout maurice kalt règne
sur une égypte prospère et stable
son initiative de débarrasser le sphinx
du sable accumulé sur un millénaire
semble être resté comme la plus grande
de ces réalisations
[Musique]
s'ensuit un siècle d'opulence l'egypte
se prélassent dans une abondance d'or et
de richesses les égyptiens anciens
s'épanouissant création artistique en
même temps qu'il se mette à vénérer une
kyrielle de dieu une période de paix et
de stations mais à laquelle une crise
vient subitement mettre un terme
tout commence avec l'arrivée d'un
personnage qui deviendra bientôt
pharaons
un homme dont on s'attache curieusement
à fond c'est l'image
[Musique]
qui
pour
[Musique]